Welcome back everyone this be my new marvel
what if episode 9 post credit scene video
and season 2 teaser They also use a lot of
the other ending scene moments with the characters
to set up what's gonna be happening in season
2.
Including paying off the missing iron man
episode.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos I
will do videos for what if season 2 when it
starts and I will be doing videos for Hawkeye
episodes.
That's actually the next big marvel Disney
plus series that were getting episodes for
before the end of the year real quick spoiler
warning if you have not seen what if episode
nine will be talking about everything that
happened, but at the end of the episode dark
Doctor Strange in the watcher work together
to trap Kilmonger with the infinity armor
who's fighting Ultron who's been taken over
by Arnim Zola's AI that's also right out of
the comics to Arnim Zola putting himself in
a robot body in then manifesting the stomach
base.
But Doctor Strange traps them inside a pocket
dimension and then keeps them within his pocket
dimension.
So is like a pocket dimension inside a pocket
dimension energy is going to watch them now
like the watcher watches the entire multiverse.
You could call this version of Doctor Strange
the watcher and training.
They haven't confirmed whether or not he's
coming back during season 2.
But I believe that they will bring this character
back is because they spent so much time developing
him and he plays such an important role in
the multiverse now you also do remember that
this version is way more powerful than MCU
Doctor Strange even though when we get to
Doctor Strange multiverse of madness and Spider-Man
no way home.
Our main version of Doctor Strange inside
the MCU main universe will be the most powerful
that he's ever been with the exception of
Scarlet witch wielding the darkhold he is
supposed to be the most powerful sorcerer
in the universe.
That's ascending all the characters back Peggy
Carter's Captain Carter asks for the avengers
endgame ending that they gave Captain America
in the main universe dissenter back to 1942
so that she can have a similar ending moment
going back to her version of Steve Rogers
the way to Captain America went back to be
with Peggy Carter in 1942.
Even though he has the power to do that he
claims that he can't do that because this
era the air that he pulls her from in present
day of her universe needs Captain Carter,
that's a bit of a lead in for what if season
two.
Because she will be coming back during season
to this version of Captain Carter, but is
also set up for the big payoff with the hydra
stopper version of the winter soldier in the
post credit scene.
Like this hydra stopper winter soldier version
of Steve Rogers needs Captain Carter and as
we learned from that dark Doctor Strange scene
when he's holding a pocket universe.
He tells the watcher you knew everything that
was going to happen before it happened.
So that means that the watcher knew that Peggy
Carter was going to meet the hydra stopper
winter soldier.
Which is why he said no I can't send you back
this era needs Captain Carter and as he sensed
her back to the exact moment that she left
from she still mid fight with that version
about trope the leaper her version of black
widow does her solid and takes him out with
the widow sting they claims the whole reason
why his group was on this ship was to steal
the hydra stopper winter soldier didn't say
who they were there to steal it for but is
probably something related to Nick fury during
the winter soldier movie, the haughty in the
winter soldier movie.
If it wasn't clear is that they were there
to mask what was going on with the big hydra
plot with those big Helicarrier's there was
the Arnim Zola AI that they're trying to get
information on so is all about Nick fury trying
to find out what was really going on inside
shield people keeping secrets within the organization
in unmasking what hydra was really doing because
he never fully trusted the other people that
he was working under and shield.
So what they're trying to imply here is that
this is basically a version of skinny boy
Steve Rogers in the hydra stopper who has
somehow captured by Hydra after the end of
episode one in turn it into a version of the
winter soldier with a few big twists instead
of revolving around the super soldier serum
that they gave the Bucky to turn him into
winter soldier along with the brainwashing
this is all about the hydra stopper technology.
So they just gave him upgraded versions of
the hydra stopper over arrows as they unthought
him for missions.
He looks like he's being kept in an actual
prison cell and you see all this cold storage
gear around him.
So the ideas they put them on ice and unthought
him and that's how he survived the present
day same way the Bucky survived to present
day.
Although also having the super soldier serum
slows down the aging process for him.
So it's a little bit different for Bucky.
But then the whole season two teaser here
where they're basically setting up an episode
for her is where they do a winter soldier
episode.
But it's the hydra stopper.
So he's been brainwashed and she has to bring
him back the same way that Steve Rogers tried
to bring back Bucky obviously got a lot of
help in the MCU.
Like you have shuri deprogramming him were
basically he has all this PTSD that they don't
really pay off and deal with until you get
to the falcon and winter soldier series.
The what if episodes tend to blow through
the plots of the marvel movies so I have a
feeling by the end of whatever winter soldier
episode that they do during season to where
they pay all the stuff off he'll be much closer
to coming back to his senses then winter soldier
was after the winter soldier movie for those
you complaining about not getting that Iron
Man Saqqara episode.
They dropped a lot of teasers for that, during
the episode.
The showrunner basically claimed that we would
see that episode.
During season two.
Like they had shifted fully to season two
really minor changes that they have to make
that episodes at a few things just to bring
in the continuity with what's going to be
happening with the overarching plot in season
two.
With whoever the new main villain is in the
new reason for the guardians in the multiverse
to crossover one of the quotes.
The showrunner gave about it.
She said wait to you see how Gamora got that
armor.
So the Iron Man Saqqara episode will be one
of the early episodes of season two.
Maybe not the first episode, but one of the
first episodes.
If you rewatched that seen in the episode
that she kind give you pretty good idea for
what happened the basic ideas that Iron Man
and Gamora get sent to Sakaar instead of Thor
in the hulk and they wind up having to battle
each other in the contest of champions in
because he's wearing the trashbuster armor
like the Iron Man armor made from all the
technology that he dumpster dive while he
was on Saqqara the grandmaster forces them
to fight in then they have to go up against
Thanos with another version of the infinity
gauntlet and use the infinity crusher to get
rid of that universes version of the infinity
stones.
After which they melt down their version of
the infinity gauntlet.
Like the scene as it played out in the episode
was actually meant to be what happened after
the end of that episode.
The same way that they revisited the plots
of all the episodes when they were collecting
all the heroes in the finale.
Like you see what happened after the big ending
cliffhangers so it sounds like the plot of
that Iron Man Saqqara episode basically played
out the same way the timeline of Thor Ragnarok
through the post credit scene in thanos showing
up at the very beginning of Avengers infinity
war played out the is a big thing.
They confirm for season two that they teaser
the showrunner was dropping is that they would
incorporate plots and characters from the
brand-new marvel phase 4 stuff that's been
happening in the new movies and the new Disney
plus series.
Like characters and plot from Wandavision.
Like a version of Agatha Harkness from a different
universe version of upgraded scarlet witch
with more powerful chaos magic in the darkhold
like Billy and Tommy Loki characters like
Kang the conqueror Loki variants like Sylvie
the TVA characters like Owen Wilson's Mobius
and Renslayer maybe Alligator Loki.
Hopefully I feel like he would be perfect
for animation.
But the showrunner also mentioned characters
in the shang chi movie eternal's characters
including the celestial switchmen she hoping
for two.
Like everybody was thinking of galactus when
they had that big episode eight twist where
the version of Ultron eight the galaxy doing
really weird really cosmic stuff is perfect
for animation.
Just because there's no budgetary constraints
for stuff like that.
And as you saw during the marvel zombies episode,
they didn't have any problem doing a version
of Spider-Man's of the movie Spider-Man stuff
happening during season two.
But they've written all the scripts so I don't
know for can see a lot of stuff with sinister
six characters are Spider-Man no way home
plot.
It also means we probably won't see fantastic
four characters or big X-Men characters until
like what if season three or season four.
Until those movies actually happen inside
the MCU.
But with each new season however many seasons
they go.
Like 45 seasons though just work in new characters
that we just seen in the brand-new marvel
movies in Marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5, eventually
it even though they bring back the guardians
of the multiverse season to season the ideas
that they'll cycle most of the roster.
The only person that confirmed is coming back
is Captain Carter here, but they could be
bringing back other characters to in the movie
actors will also come back to play their characters
from you yet other different universes.
Probably the best example that is the Chadwick
postman may he rest in peace played for different
versions of Black Panther during the what
if episodes.
So you see other MCU actors doing that too
with other versions of characters in future
seasons.
And while the showrunner had been teasing
season two plot in the episodes.
What was going to be happening.
She also revealed that they had been developing
a full-blown what if spinoff series.
Just for Chadwick postman's version of T'challa
starlord like there were going to do at T'challa
starlord series by itself obviously that was
in development before he passed away.
But the ideas that any of these big what if
characters alternate universe versions are
fair game to get their own big spinoff if
the movie actors are down to do that they
they just announced a full-blown live-action
Wandavision spinoff for Agatha Harkness everyone
Q the music.
It was Agatha all along that he would that
series is village to explore more of her timeline.
Like what happens after marvel phase for the
last time we start the end of Wandavision
in more of what happened in her past, because
she's been around since the Salem witch trials
she also come back during future marvel movies
as well to.
Not just this new full-blown Agatha Harkness
series.
But it is any big Easter eggs that you spotted
in the post credit scene that I didn't talk
about during this or any big questions that
you have about what if season two.
Just right them blown the comments and all
address in my future bonus videos Hawkeye
episodes are starting in a couple weeks will
also get a new Hawkeye trailer.
Pretty soon to.
They just released a new eternal trailer video's
will do a video for that there's a bunch of
big trailers that just drops will try to get
to those as fast as possible and next week
is a brand-new Batman movie trailer and DC
Fandome coming with a bunch of trailers for
the DC movies.
Of course will do all the videos for that
step.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel to be the first to see those everyone
click here for my full what if episode 9 finale
video and click here for my brand-new House
the Dragon trailer video and game of thrones
Easter eggs.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys next one!